MANDY WAITE: And
I'm Andy Waite.
I'm a developer [INAUDIBLE]
for the Google Cloud platform.
We're absolutely thrilled today
to have with us Dame
Wendy Hall.
Wendy Hall is a professor of
computer science at University
of Southampton in the UK.
She is also the dean of the
faculty of physical sciences
and engineering.
She has published over 400
papers and she is frequently
invited to speak
at high profile
conferences and events.
Together with Sir Tim
Berners-Lee and Nigel
Shadbolt, she co-founded the
Web Science Research
Initiative, and she's
a director of
the Web Science Trust.
Not only is she a Dame Commander
of the British
Empire, but she's also, I'm very
jealous here, a fellow of
the Royal Society, and she's
also a former president of the
Association of Computing
Machinery, the first person
outside of North America ever
to hold that position.
Welcome Wendy.
Thank you for coming.
DAME WENDY HALL: Oh, it's
a pleasure to be here.
Nice to be with you.
EMMA JACKSON: So we mentioned
in your bio that you
co-founded the world's first
inter disciplinary body to
study the structure and
sociology of the web.
Can you tell us a bit more about
what you're doing with
that organization?
DAME WENDY HALL: The
Web Science Trust?
EMMA JACKSON: The Web
Science Trust.
DAME WENDY HALL: Well, when we
were thinking about this back
in 2005, 2006, Tim, Nigel and I,
and Danny Weitzner, who is
a lawyer who worked with Tim at
MIT on policy and has since
been in the White House, we were
thinking about how the
web evolved.
And we were actually thinking
about why the semantic web
wasn't taking off.
Why people weren't rushing to
develop links for data, as
well as documents.
And in looking back at how
the web evolved, we
realized that we just--
despite the fact that one of
us was the inventor of the
web, we so little understood
how it happened.
And we also began to realize
that this wasn't just about
the technology.
It was about what people did
with the technology.
And in fact, what society did
with the technology over time,
and how the circle of the
technology goes out, people do
things with it, and then
the technology changes.
So there is a feedback loop.
And it's very different to the
way we were used to designing
computer systems.
And so we thought, well,
actually, it's so important
that we understand this.
It's a whole new discipline.
And it is very interdisciplinary
because we
need social scientists, and
technologists, and lawyers,
and economists, and business
studies, and maths and
psychology, and so many
different subjects that
impinge on this.
We decided to give it a name.
We called it web science,
for good or bad.
Many people think we're
saying websites.
But it's website.
And there's two things we don't
like about that name.
One is web, and the other is
sites because it makes it feel
more technical than
it's meant to be.
And there were people start
studying this, but it didn't
have a name, it didn't have any
cohesion or coordination.
And the Web Science Research
Initiative was an agreement
between Southampton and MIT--
those two universities backed
us in developing this.
And then over the next three
years, we evolved it into the
Web Science Trust, which
is a Charitable Trust
based in the UK.
But it's a global reach.
And it's mission is to promote
awareness of websites research
and websites education
around the world.
And now we have a network of
50 laboratories around the
world who coordinate their
efforts in web science, do
collaborative research, and
share education experiences.
And many people now run
web science programs.
And we have an annual
conference.
Next week, it's in Paris.
And we run workshops and thought
leadership events, and
just generally raise the
awareness of what we think is
a really important paradigm
shift in the way systems are
developed and help us think
about how this ecosystem might
evolve in the future.
MANDY WAITE: OK, so in terms
of in terms of web science,
you've kind of been over what
the fundamentals of it are.
But it's kind of like a science
such as physics or
chemistry, so you're applying
that to the web, and the web
is constantly evolving
in front of us.
Things are changing, and we
don't quite understand it.
It's almost organic in the way
that it grows and changes, and
the way hot spots kind of
appear, and things change.
So you mentioned web
laboratories.
What do you do in a
web laboratory?
DAME WENDY HALL: Well, this is
absolutely crucial to what's
happening because we've
built the system.
It's built by human beings.
But it isn't a natural system.
So you can't apply the laws
of biology to it.
So you can say it evolves, but
it doesn't evolve in the same
way that plants evolve--
or does it?
I mean, what are the laws
of evolution of the web?
And there's an engineering piece
to it because engineers
design the protocols that
make things happen.
And then some of them fail--
lots of them fail.
People try to build applications
and companies.
Some succeed-- lots
of them fail.
And in order to study this,
as you say, it's
evolving all the time.
And it's getting bigger
all the time.
It's a huge--
you can't take a snapshot and
say you understand it.
And you can't take just study it
in the UK, or in China, or
in the US, or in
one university.
So you've got to do, we think,
longitudinal studies.
And you've got to be capturing
what's happening
day in and day out.
We talk about building web
science observatories to
monitor the trends,
what's emerging.
And it's not just about what's
happening on the web.
But what's the technology
development piece?
And what are the
policy pieces?
When a government changes the
law or a regulation, changes
its policy about something, what
impact does that have?
And you have to follow that
over a period of time.
So we've got people observing
and doing experiments with the
data that's being gathered about
what's going on the web.
But we're actually, with our
labs, and with companies that
are working with us, developing
this concept of web
observatories.
And I liken it to, you know, in
order to understand climate
science, you have to people
around the world taking the
temperature day in, day out, all
the time, how much has the
ice melted.
They've got to be doing
that day in, day out.
We have to be monitoring
the web 24/7.
And people are doing that but
they're doing it and storing
the data on their systems,
but in silos, not shared.
MANDY WAITE: You mentioned.
DAME WENDY HALL: [INAUDIBLE]
so we want to develop protocols
and guidelines so
that we can share the data
that's being collected and the
tools that are being developed
to analyze that data, both in
and university research
laboratories, and by
companies--
share the tools as much as
possible to help us build a
bigger and better picture of
what's going on, and how
things develop and
emerge over time.
MANDY WAITE: You mentioned the
regional aspects of it--
that you have to do it not just
in the UK, not just in
China, but everywhere.
And the cultural diversity.
I mean, I've used the web
in Japan and China.
And it's very much significantly
different there
than it is here.
Is it really possible to do that
kind of study equally?
Is it possible to say, it's
more like a sociological
study, where you have the
cultural differences between
people, and you have to
understand how they relate to
each other?
But obviously, the way they use
the web is different from
the way we use the web.
How do you balance that?
How do you get that right?
DAME WENDY HALL: Well, again, I
think you have to gather the
data and the evidence.
Otherwise, you're hypothesizing
without those
facts and evidence.
And we have a Ph.D. program
at Southampton.
And we've taken our students
to other labs around the
world-- to China, and Korea, and
the States, and other labs
in Europe to share
experiences.
And that is so powerful, to get
them to think about how
Twitter is used.
I mean, even now in
China, they have
their Twitter, Weibo.
And getting the students to
compare what they tweet about
and what are the big stories
is very insightful.
And there's a huge social piece,
a social science piece,
understanding how
society works.
And the coming together of the
social and the technical is
quite difficult to manage.
But that's the exciting
challenge of it.
And I just love sharing the
experiences between the
different cultures.
But we want the evidence
for that.
We want to collect the data for
the students to analyze.
EMMA JACKSON: It's a fascinating
area, yeah.
MANDY WAITE: It is a
fascinating area.
EMMA JACKSON: I was wondering if
you think, maybe because I
know you've done a lot of work
to try and encourage more
girls and women to get
into this area.
So do you think maybe web
science is something that
would encourage more
diversity?
DAME WENDY HALL:
Well, it does.
And after 30 years in the
business of computer science,
it's wonderful to walk into a
classroom and have 50% of the
audience women.
Web science naturally attracts
women because it doesn't
require people to be technically
minded in order to
be involved in the work
and the study.
You still need programmers in
there to build the tools that
you're going to use to analyze
the data and have those
technical insights.
And it's that mix that's
so exciting.
And our students at Southampton,
our Ph.D.
Students, they come from every
different type of discipline
on to the web science
Ph.D. Program.
And they have to have two Ph.D.
supervisors , and at
least one of those must be an
non-computer scientist.
And, actually, several of the
students on the program happen
two supervisors, neither of whom
are computer scientists.
It is not just about
the technology.
The insights are amazing,
what we get from that.
And it's just a natural that
this is a diverse group of
people that want to do it.
We're just launching, in
Southampton, an undergraduate
program starting in October.
And we've got two pathways
at the moment.
These students will get a BSE
in web science, but for the
moment, they can come in with
either a computer science-type
background, so technical type
background, or a social
science-type background and have
training in their core
disciplines, and training in web
science-type fundamentals,
and then can weave their way to
a web science degree coming
in from different backgrounds.
And next year, we'll add
a management pathway.
And then there's going to be
a humanities pathway, and a
legal pathway--
oh, it's so exciting.
It's one of the most exciting
things I've ever done,
developing this undergraduate
program.
MANDY WAITE: That's interesting
that you talk
about the courses that are being
offered by Southampton
University.
Are MIT doing something
similar as well?
DAME WENDY HALL:
Well, no not--
I mean, obviously,
they're part--
because this is one of the
places it started--
they're part of the web science
laboratory network.
They are developing new
types of courses.
But they are more on the high
school slant of things.
We work very well together, so
we ask students to talk to
each other.
MANDY WAITE: So basically, I
have this question about the
courses that are being offered
by Southampton University.
So you have the undergraduate
course, and then you have,
also, this doctoral training
lab that offers Ph.D and
Master's courses.
But the question would have
been, just simply, what would
be the role of the web scientist
that these courses
would produce.
But my question, I want to
expand it now because I know
when I look at physics--
I mean, physicists are moving
towards a certain goal.
They are trying to discover the
key to the universe and to
understand how the universe
evolves--
DAME WENDY HALL: Well, we're
trying to discover the key to
the digital universe.
This is so important.
MANDY WAITE: Well, exactly--
so what is the
outcome of web science?
DAME WENDY HALL: Well, what's
the outcome of web science?
We are trying to understand
the digital universe.
And our thesis is, it is a
new type of discipline.
I genuinely believe that this is
as big a paradigm shift as
the paradigm shift that happened
in the '50s when we
started developing computer
science as a subject based on
the concept of Turing
machines.
And now this is a
new discipline.
What's happened to the internet
and the web has
created a whole new
way of building
and designing systems.
And in fact, Tim
gave it a name.
When he we wrote his book
"Weaving the Web," he talked
about the type of systems that
the applications that we would
be able to develop
on the web--
he talked about them as
being social machines.
These are systems where the
machines do the administration
and the people do
the creativity.
And that's what we're seeing.
You see, Google is
a social machine.
Amazon is a social machine.
Twitter is a social machine.
The web itself is a
social machine.
It's where you've got computers
and people working,
collectively, together and using
the network effect, to
create things that didn't exist
before, that couldn't
exist before, like Wikipedia.
It's an example of something
that's being
created in that way.
And understanding that creation
process is, we think,
something really different to
what's happened before.
So I haven't really answered
your question.
I've opened it up in a different
sort of way.
So I think the web science
itself is trying to understand
the laws, what can you say--
if you think about when we
talked about different
cultures, the web in the UK or
the US compared to the web in
China, there are some
things that--
you need search engines.
Whatever you do, you need
a search engine.
And the social networks
evolve.
There's no stopping them, but
what people use those for are
very different in the
different cultures.
And I think businesses need to
understand, especially, in the
digital world, where you are
running a global business, and
you might say, well, if I'm
going to sell this product,
it'll be the same in the
US as it will in China.
And it won't.
But anyway, putting all these
pieces, together, so web
science is the study of this
phenomenon, and trying to see
if there are rules,
and theories, that
you can say are givens.
But then web scientists are the
sort of people that are
going to help businesses and
governments understand how to
work with this type of evolution
of this type of
system and think about what's
going to happen in the future.
So it won't be a black
and white science.
You won't be able to say, yes,
if you do this, then that will
definitely happen.
But it will be, if you do this,
then that might happen.
And if you don't do this, then
this will never happen.
And particularly, we want to
give evidence for policy
makers and big companies to
think about what their future
might be as these trends emerge
and what are the good
and bad things to do.
MANDY WAITE: Is it likely--
sorry to keep asking
questions, but--
DAME WENDY HALL:
No, please do.
MANDY WAITE: Is it likely that
we're going to expand web
science to other science
universities for
that country, rapidly?
I mean, is it going to be
limited to Southampton for
some time, or are we going
to see this [INAUDIBLE]
everywhere?
DAME WENDY HALL: Well,
not everybody
calls it web science.
There's lots happening in the
States, but they don't always
call it web science.
Some people call it social
computation.
I just think that more and
more people are copying,
mirroring, what we're doing.
And as I said, we've got this
network of 14 laboratories
around the world who are all
themselves web science
laboratories.
And they have Ph.D. programs and
are beginning to develop
undergraduate programs.
And there are lots of master's
programs called web science.
The worrying thing is,
I looked at one.
I won't name the university.
It was somewhere in the States,
not one of the big--
and it was advertising a
Master's in web science.
And when I looked at it, it was
a computer science with
one web technology module.
And it's like, yeah, that's
not web science.
But hey, what can you do?
The cat's out of the bag.
And people we'll make of
it what they will.
But I know what I mean by it.
EMMA JACKSON: So you talk
about these sort of web
scientists, I guess, that
monitor trends in technology
and the web--
DAME WENDY HALL: They're sort
the information scientists of
the future.
EMMA JACKSON: Yeah, well
I was wondering--
one of the trends at the moment
is this advancement in
technology to help education, in
some way, things like these
massive open online courses--
DAME WENDY HALL: The MOOCs.
EMMA JACKSON: The MOOCs,
as they are.
So, being in education yourself,
what do you think
about these new advancements
and how they might change--
well, you see, they are
not new, really.
I cut my teeth on the use of
computers in education.
And up until now, we've talked
a lot about computers were
going to completely
revolutionize education.
And they haven't--
they have changed, for example,
everywhere you go
now, classrooms, universities,
are full of computers.
Students use computers.
They write their essays
on computers.
They hand them in digitally.
That talk to their
tutors by email.
That has fundamentally
changed.
But actually, if you want a
degree, generally speaking,
you go to a campus university
and study for a degree.
That has not changed.
The MOOCs are a buzzy thing.
This idea that you can teach a
course using video and the
self-assessment material online,
and have hundreds of
thousands of people look
at it, and then get a
qualification, or get certified
for that course, and
then build up to a degree.
And if this is really shown to
work, then that will radically
change how we do education,
both in
universities and schools.
But there's a big sociological
piece to this.
Do young teenagers need
to learn in a cohort?
Do they need that psychological
encouragement of
their peers and their tutors, in
a physical environment, in
order to learn?
You can't send somebody
to a library.
I don't think you can
send a teenager to a
library and say, look.
They can go read a book
but they can't learn.
A mature student, very different
kettle of fish.
There's many master's courses
which are delivered online
successfully because mature
students want to learn.
They've already learned
how to learn.
Either they've done a degree
before or they've worked
through by learning
while they work.
And they're paying for something
that they want to
do, and they already have
families and stuff.
But I think the jury is out
on whether that's how
18-year-olds can do it.
But I do think it, potentially,
does say, you no
longer need to campus
university, or, dare I say it,
a physical, bricks and
mortar school.
But I think the universities
have really got to look at
what their future is if this
technology does take hold.
It's very interesting.
And you could say this is a web
science thing, but it's an
educational thing as well.
And I find the whole
thing fascinating.
We are actually, just to be
incestuous, we're doing a MOOC
about web science at
Southampton, which should be
online in the Autumn.
So we'll see how that goes.
MANDY WAITE: So you, back before
the advent of the world
wide web, you and the team
from the University of
Southampton invented Microcosm,
which was one of
the very first hypermedia
servers.
And probably, can expand on what
hypermedia servers are,
but it's very similar to what
we have today in the web.
And at the time, you've spoken
about this in other lectures
and such, like in other
speeches you've done.
There was a BBC documentary
called "Hyperland" that
starred Douglas Adams and
was also written by him.
And it also starred the fourth
Doctor Who, Thom Baker.
He played a software agent.
And I think Douglas Adams
played a kind
of bored couch potato.
And Thom Baker introduced him
to the notion of hypermedia.
DAME WENDY HALL: He introduced
him to the idea of finding
anything he wanted when
he wanted it.
MANDY WAITE: So Microcosm,
really, kind of,
was born out of that--
or at least she said.
So I'm just really interested
to understand
the reality of it.
You've said before that it
really inspired you to go out
and build microcosm.
How much is that true?
DAME WENDY HALL: It's
absolutely true.
I was really getting into the
idea of using computers in
education--
this concept of multimedia,
which, in those days, was
analog video, audio on tape,
text from the files, and
somehow we got all that together
on one computer
screen and linked it all up.
And it was very primitive
compared to
what we have today.
But you could see
the potential.
And I met the gurus
of hypertext.
And I met Ted Nelson and Doug
Engelbart/ And that was the
first hypertext conference,
[INAUDIBLE] hypertext
conference in 1987.
There was a very sort
of timely--
there was a time when this
was all emerging.
At the same time, in CERN, Tim
was this inventing the web.
And that "Hyperland" video
was released in 1987.
That was the year that Apple
released Hypercard.
And I watched the TV program.
And I thought, I want to build
a system like that.
I want to build a system with a
software agent that helps me
find the information I
want when I want it.
And I'm convinced that
hypertext, hypermedia, is
crucial to this.
And so we set about developing
this system, Microcosm--
it wasn't the first.
There had been hypertext
systems for a couple of
decades before that.
But what we did with Microcosm
was, we stored the links
separately from the documents.
They were first-class
entities.
And they had meaning.
They weren't just point
to point links.
The information encoded
to them said why
that link was created.
So it was a precursor to the
semantic web, actually.
But what we got wrong, what
Tim taught me, was A, this
stuff works if-- either
nobody will use it or
everybody will use it.
And so it's going to work
over the network.
It's going to be
open and free.
And to the protocols, the
standards have got to be open.
Microcosm was proprietary.
And so those were the
things that Tim got
right with the web.
Give it away, open protocols,
on the network.
And so we got a lot of that
wrong with Microcosm.
But we did get the idea of
having intelligent linking.
And that's really what's
exciting, for me, about what's
happening now is that's
the semantic web.
And that's what we're
seeing emerge today.
So it's about 20 years--
or more--
22, 23 years since we first
of did Microcosm.
It's exciting to
see those ideas
emerging in today's work.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah,
definitely yeah.
EMMA JACKSON: So in today's
web, what excites you in
technology at the moment?
DAME WENDY HALL: Well, I think
we are seeing the semantic web
emerge-- the web of data, Web
3.0, the idea that we're not
just thinking documents,
we're linking data.
And we're linking data in such
a way that there's that
meaning about why that
link is there.
That means you've got to, of
course, you have to tag them.
You've got to explain what--
you've got to say what the
data's about.
You have to have ontologies.
But you can do in a
very simple way.
And we are really beginning to
see that emerge with, Google's
got its knowledge tree.
And that's really exciting.
The other exciting thing, of
course, it's all happening in
the mobile world.
And the 80% of the world that
isn't on the internet is
getting on the internet through
the mobile technology.
So we're seeing another whole
scale up of this amazing
ecosystem that we've
developed.
And I think that it's changed
the world already, but we
haven't seen anything yet.
MANDY WAITE: I did have a
sweepstake about how many
times you would use
the word ontology.
DAME WENDY HALL: Once.
I tried not to.
MANDY WAITE: Because web
scientists, generally, are
very averse to using
the word ontology.
Why is that?
DAME WENDY HALL: Well, I think
because it seems to sort of
overcomplicates the issue.
And you you don't have to
develop a perfect ontology in
order to share linking
information--
share information.
MANDY WAITE: I think the
semantic web probably explains
it a bit better.
I think even in semantic web, it
might still be a little too
complicated for people
to understand.
So is there a better way we
can actually frame it?
DAME WENDY HALL: Well, I've
talked about the intelligent
web, really.
And so, nowadays, if you look
for something, you use a
search engine like Google, you
get a list of links back.
In the future, we'll look for
something, and we'll get the
information that we wanted
to answer the
question that we had.
MANDY WAITE: It'll
be contextual.
I have an idea.
You could call web
science webology.
DAME WENDY HALL: Actually,
it was one of the
things we went through.
But we decided that didn't
sound serious enough.
[LAUGHTER]
EMMA JACKSON: -ology,
that's good.
DAME WENDY HALL: We did,
that was on our--
Tim wanted to call it
philosophical engineering.
MANDY WAITE: Oh, no.
EMMA JACKSON: That
would be wild.
DAME WENDY HALL: Yeah, and we
decided people wouldn't
understand what.
But that's what it
actually is.
EMMA JACKSON: Well,
thank you so much.
DAME WENDY HALL:
Is the time up?
MANDY WAITE: Well, we can
talk about more--
what other questions
do we have?
[INAUDIBLE]
EMMA JACKSON: I think yeah.
MANDY WAITE: OK, guess so.
Thank you for coming today.
It's been wonderful
having you here.
And I learned about web science
because web science
had been new to me anyway.
So it's been a really real
experience and a joy,
actually, watching you
talk about it.
DAME WENDY HALL: It's been
fantastic to have the
opportunity to talk about it.
I should add that,
as I said to you
before, it doesn't mean--
I don't always want women
to do computer science.
I think it's really important
that we get women into
computer science.
And it's such an uphill
battle for us.
We need to look to the countries
like the Far East
and India, where women aspire
to be computer scientists.
We don't have that
culture here.
And we somehow need
to get that buzz.
And I'm hopeful, but I don't
have that problem with web
science because this is
something that women naturally
want to study, so that's--
[? MANDY WAITE: Oh, again, ?]
but women [INAUDIBLE]
it's a kind of clever way at try
to present more models to
young women--
EMMA JACKSON: Yeah,
such as yourself.
Yeah.
MANDY WAITE: Such as
yourself, yeah.
So hopefully, we're
doing that.
And thank you for
coming on today.
It's been really wonderful
to talk to you.
EMMA JACKSON: Yeah, I've
enjoyed it so much.
DAME WENDY HALL: My pleasure.
MANDY WAITE: And thanks
to Emma, thanks to
our producer Ian.
And this was "Women
Techmakers," from campus London.
We'll hopefully have another
event for you soon.
In the meantime, good-bye.
DAME WENDY HALL: Bye.